les pêcheurs du golfe du saint-laurent
le disent depuis longtemps la population
de phoques gris menace certains poissons
de fond comme la morue et de récentes
études tendent à leur donner raison le
phoque gris empêcherait non seulement le
retour de la morue mais certains
chercheurs prédisent même la disparition
de ce poisson dans le sud du golfe un
constat qui soulève une question
délicate faut-il contrôler la population
de phoques gris pour protéger la
biodiversité de cet écosystème
on se cache pour oser l'on a toujours
été un peuple que la nuque unis vital
à commencer par bruno du haut-rhin et
l'hiver est toujours très très dur aux
îles
la première viande fraîche cardinal pour
l'écolo
c'était les loups marins
le loup marin aux îles de la madeleine
cette chasse traditionnelle a longtemps
été décrié elle reste encore aujourd'hui
un sujet sensible et controversés
mais qu'arrive-t-il quand les
populations de phoques explose quand
l'abondance d'une espèce le phoque gris
menace la diversité d'un écosystème
la prédation par l'euphorie empêchent le
retour de mon mieux pour la morue on
parle d'une disparition potentielle
d'ici 20 ans dans le sud du golfe
c'est homardiers rentrer de la pêche et
encore une fois les coffres sont bien
emplie mais curieusement ce n'est pas dû
aux morts dont tout le monde parle ici
plus qu
il a plus de fonds que rick lavables
le tout pour le tout nouveau duo va tout
est à
conquérir dans la peau de chasse
la peau de chasse qui se fait ce afin
que
le toeloop augmente ou
le faux glisse amusé avec les causes et
s'amuse avec l'apport s'amuse avec les
bouées emails les bruits
safex
climatique
au sénat manche il manger aux marchés
nourrissent de ce curieux
chalot pêche aussi le flétan une autre
espèce qui est devenu la cible de
phoques gris on les arabes se nomme sens
puis le teint concon confesse notre zone
de pêche ben il ya l'eau paiement
souples et ans a déjà arrivé d'être hall
avec 100 disciples est temps de manger
complètement et laisse éclater est avec
les haddad du poisson
le pêcheur a dirigé un groupe de travail
sur le phoque gris il est plus que
jamais convaincu que cette espèce nuit
aux pêcheurs des îles c'est sûr que
quinze mille fois gueuler dans la
grandeur du canada c'est bien mais
madeleine quitté le communaux c'est une
surpopulation qui porte sur le nom
gauvreau le phoque gris a toujours été
présent dans les eaux du saint-laurent
mais l'essentiel du troupeau était
surtout confiné à l'île de sable une île
à l'extérieur du golfe mais depuis que
l'espèce connaît une croissance
exponentielle les colonies se
multiplient un peu partout
le phoque gris est maintenant présent
dans tout le golfe de la nouvelle écosse
jusqu'à la basse côte nord
on estime qu'il y avait quinze mille
phoques gris dans les années 60 on en
dénombre aujourd'hui près d'un demi
million
on a voulu connaître l'impact d'autant
de phoque sur l'écosystème du
saint-laurent
mike hamel a passé toute sa vie à
étudier les phoques du saint laurent
il nous amène au large des côtes du parc
du bic
mike et son équipe vont capturer des
phoques communs une espèce qui subit
l'arrivée des phoques gris dans le
secteur chaque année à plus d'efforts
gré dans la coin dans tout et autant de
monde qu'on voit plus d'euphorie à moins
de fonds communs
des confirmations
si on parle beaucoup plus du fond de
grille que de toute autre espèce c'est
que le phoque gris est la seule espèce à
passer toute l'année dans le golfe ils
causent donc plus de dommages aux pêches
l'augmentation du phoque gris s'explique
par le réchauffement du climat qui fait
disparaître les glaces ce qui favorise
les mises bas sur les plages les mesures
de conservation ont aussi profité à
cette espèce de
chasse c'est quelqu'un voyez info qui
voulait chasser un pot la viande ou des
espèces nuisibles aussi à pendant les
années 60 et s'il y avait un abattage
gouvernementale pourrait limiter la
croissance de population
[Musique]
en
l'autre raison c'est que le phoque gris
n'a plus que prédateur naturel on a
complètement exterminer les morses des
îles de la madeleine et on a presque à
néant si les populations des polars et
de grands requins dans le golfe
aucune 2 c'est beaucoup la fois gris et
la nourriture y est pas des dérangements
pas de planète a donc cessé les
conditions qui sont bons pour août
[Musique]
ce fonds commun une fois adulte se
nourrira surtout d'invertébrés et d'un
peu de poisson ce qui est tout le
contraire du phoque gris
gris peut manger
de poisson
les pêcheurs affirment depuis longtemps
que le troupeau de phoques gris devenue
une flottille de pêche incontrôlée mais
pour incriminer cette espèce il fallait
des preuves solides
[Musique]
il y a quelques années mike a fait une
découverte qui a secoué le monde dépêche
c'est un pacha crime a dit mike il faut
te le garder les enfants qui mangent des
brûlés moi je dis oui on dansait dans
toutes les études confère ne jamais vu
beaucoup beaucoup mais a cessé dans le
détroit de capotes on est allé puis
c'est quand 5 remportant le diet c'était
l'amour ou le chercheur a démontré que
le phoque gris manches surtout les
grosses morue il concentre donc sa diète
sur les géniteurs et s'attaque ainsi aux
derniers contingents de morue dans le
sud du golfe
aujourd'hui l'évidence pointe vers le
phoque gris comme cause des déclins à en
continu mais on peut pas c'est certain
que c'est pô le phoque gris qui est en
cause de ce qui se passe depuis 30 40
ans la pêche a beaucoup contribué en ce
qui concerne la morue
aujourd'hui ce qu'on peut en conclure ce
que la prédation par le phoque gris
empêchent le retour de la morue
oui
où
vous
pour la morue on parle d'une disparition
potentielle d'ici 20 ans en dessous du
golfe une benoît a démontré que le
phoque gris ferait aussi disparaître
d'autres espèces de poissons de fond
dans quelques décennies c ur finalement
conduire qu'il leur à cestas et combien
espèces qu'on va permettre maintenant de
se retrouver dans des situations
similaires qui sont dus finalement
déséquilibre que nous nous avons causé
par par nos actions peut-on freiner ces
déclins en agissant sur le phoque les
chercheurs se sont penchés sur la
délicate question de la chasse il
faudrait abattre au moins 6000 phoques
par année
on cherche à avoir une chasse très
précautionneux ceux des prélèvements qui
permettrait à la fois leur établissement
pour ces espèces de poissons mais aussi
qu'ils respecteraient la conservation du
fauve du riz
[Musique]
on peut chasser le phoque gris on peut
se porter facilement chasse beaucoup
plus élevé ceux ci dessus qui deviennent
intéressants pour certains communauté
c'est pas une échelle industrielle zone
atlantique mais c'est pour certaines
communautés sont intéressants
[Musique]
la question qui se pose est ce que trop
de fois que c'est
c'est toujours un valeurs de société le
ministère pêches et océans quoi que ce
réseau soit une nouvelle arme noxon et
de suie qui peut développer mais c'est
aussi inédits suivis sur tout un défi
[Musique]
après la pause le phoque gris désormais
dans la mire des chasseurs
[Musique]
la chasse au phoque aux îles de la
madeleine était surtout pratiquée
jusqu'ici sur le phoque du groenland une
espèce qui se chassent uniquement en
hiver sur la banquise même si cette
chasse est toujours autorisé bien des
chasseurs l'avait abandonnée en raison
de la chute du prix de la fourrure mais
avec l'augmentation des populations de
phoques gris les madelinots propose
désormais de se tourner vers cette
espèce une de nos équipes a eu un accès
exclusif à une sortie de chasse
[Musique]
il est 4 heures du matin et on
accompagne des chasseurs vers une île
située à une heure d'ici
on sent enfin lille 1
une chiasse
un commercial de
une chasse aux phoques gris
toujours une certaine excitation
belle sortie de je chasse enfants et
quinze ans
nous avons retrouvé une équipe qu'on a
[Musique]
ozil une poignée de madelinots veut
relancer l'industrie de la chasse avec
le phoque gris ils veulent contrôler
cette espèce tout en faisant une chasse
durable et sans souffrance
on a voulu comprendre comment se fait
cette nouvelle chasse comment ils
comptent relancer cette industrie
qui galets de l'unc alors on a des
systèmes de communication fait que on va
en ligne et les culs
les clips de collector
la chasse d'été ou phoques gris est
encore toute récente
cette chasse se pratique sur des adultes
et se fait à la carabine la méthode
comporte son lot de défis
[Applaudissements]
sur la tronche possibilité de vue les
six ou où je peux leur échapper aux tirs
aux côtes
on attend vraiment qu'ils rendaient
nombre précis ici
comme le lui s'il en phase de poules
m'amuse pas si riche pour elle la bâche
à eau pour les chapeaux vivre faisait
souffrir pour le fort sont vraiment
visible au télescope il faut sauver mady
a placé pour qu'on puisse les avants
comme il y en a qui arrivent
[Applaudissements]
ozil la chasse aux phoques a surtout et
l affaire d'une espèce jusqu'ici le
phoque du groenland
cette chasse qui est toujours autorisé
ni plus ce qu'elle était
le boycott européenne de 2010 sur les
fourrures a fait mal à cette industrie à
l'origine de cet embargo des campagnes
anti chasse menée par des vedettes et
des groupes de défense des animaux
l'abattage au gourdel hakapik était jugé
trop cruelle par ces groupes bien que
les conclusions de vétérinaire et
reconnu cette méthode le canada n'a pu
empêcher l'europe de fermer ses
frontières
[Musique]
à
milan nord pour relancer l'industrie du
phoque les madelinots sont conscients
que l'abattage doit se faire sans
cruauté
avec moi je suis dans le bateau puis je
suis par les données par exemple le
temps entre le moment où le phoque est
tirée depuis le temps où il va être
récupérée où la chaleur paris pour
récupérer une fois que la distance entre
le tireur la chaloupe même sens le
tireur qui le phoque
ce genre de choses que nous on regarde
pour être sûr que c'est une chose qui se
passe sans cruauté puis en accord avec
les principes de bien-être animal
c'est pas une chose qui est cru l'an
prochain c'est absolument pas pire
qu'elle ait tiré un orignal et se
réinsère des foyers manqué le premier
coup on va on va sereinement l'on veut
l'abattre c'est vraiment la même chose
mais
ces pêches et océans canada qui
réglemente la chasse aux phoques
tous ces chasseurs détient le permis de
chasse commerciale
réjean parent tissés pour formation des
chasseurs pour partager ses expériences
pour que n'importe qui fasse n'importe
où sur la glace ou bien ici que ça sent
bon la carabine ou là où la gappe et
c'est le but premier c'est le bien-être
animal on n'est pas ici pour faire
souffrir un animal ou comme ce soir on
est ici pour pour récolter de la viande
à la chasse aux phoques gris ou bien aux
phoques du groenland fonction des coûts
ce qu'on appelle la chasse d'abattage en
trois étapes après ça s'est super
visible en ordre du les ans avec un
chasseur professionnel
c'est chasselas est vraiment bien au
cadre il
a bien longtemps
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sur le pont le capitaine ghislain cyr
récupèrent chaque quartier de viande
ya beaucoup de fautes je pense que c'est
la nourriture pour tous un amène
beaucoup
yann envoyé à sûr mais pas loin des 5
600 d'après ce que j'ai pu voir ils
prélèvent aussi des organes pour la
recherche la première fois je mesure les
passes à de gros un prince charmant ses
morceaux de muscles
tient prêt sans jamais chercher tout le
système digestif apporter de l'oesophage
jusqu'au au rectum
le coin il se nourrit c'est être
contenus stomacaux jusqu'à l'intestin ça
donne une idée de ce laps de temps s'est
nourrie by words coixet
canal et souvent
[Musique]
il n'y a plus qu'une soixantaine de
chasseurs actifs aux îles en 2008 on en
comptait quinze fois plus
cette chasse a perdu sa rentabilité et
ses chasseurs avec le boycott européen
réjean vigneau mais convaincu que les
madelinots peuvent renverser cette
tendance plus question cependant de
chasse et uniquement pour la fourrure
comme autrefois ce jeu c'est vraiment la
carcasse la carcasse de fang li jeunes
de 6 mo après sort des jurés impressions
on prélève les fuyards le boucher estime
que cette viande a tout le potentiel
pour gagner l'assiette québécoise
vient de haut de gamme d'euros de gains
quant à ses valeurs ni critiquer que
ouvrage que si de la porte et ramon
table c'est énormément de travail mais
le produit fini super beau ça fait
tellement d'années qu'on travaille qu'on
en est fier
avec cette violeau d'école tout temps
avec deux prises en 2010 et ayant parlé
du mongy du mammifère marin c'est jamais
évident région s'est associé au chef
pour convaincre les consommateurs de
l'extérieur des îles les madelinots
veulent maintenant faire du phoque gris
un produit phare du saint laurent chaque
fois tu vas parler un chef cuisinier une
nouvelle viande qui arrive je suis bien
marché c'est un produit québec comme de
raison pour rehausser d'un flauraud c
pour vu sa flore pour nous servons pour
eux sont aussi
encore long on est très très optimiste
de la colère
mais pour relancer cette industrie il
faudra plus que la seule mise en marché
la viande
rentrez rentrez
nous aimer compléter une manque une
pièce d'équipement arriver qu'est ce
qu'on voit ici c'est le chardenoux sinn
fein vraiment ainsi que la
transformation va se faire dans cette
usine on veut extraire l'huile de
chacune des carcasses de phoques on veut
en faire une huile de qualité
pharmaceutique
legrand est rempli de propriété long on
parle d'une quantité d'une qualité
d'oméga 3 qui se trouve pas vraiment
ailleurs on prendra pas un saumon pour
faire de lui le domaine l'autre on veut
manger le saumon mais le gros du phoque
on ne mangera pas on veut pas chassé
pour chasser on veut chasser pour la
viande on veut chasser pour dix grands
on veut chasser pour de la fourrure on
veut chasser pour tout ce que le phoque
moine capable de nous apporter donc ça
s'inscrit vraiment dans un cadre
écologique soit c'est important pour
tout le mans je pense que l'on crée un
débouché qui qui passe du folklore mais
vraiment vers le structurer
on n'est pas
[Musique]
les gens viennent au zèle l'été
et par tout ce que tu entends parler
s'ils sont accueillants et ils sont
gentils
comment quelqu'un devient c ou méchant
l'hiver tout à coup
mon père était chasseur mon grand pas
maison on n'est pas des barbares on dit
les chasseurs je suis fier de ce qu'on a
en main on n'a pas de bar bord
jonathan vignon est conscient que
l'opinion publique peut freiner la
nouvelle chasse aux phoques gris ce
jeune président veut changer l'image de
cette chasse m'impliquer ses parties de
m'élever l'accident de l'acadien ii ou
ce que je voyais les animals sdc tu as
tant mieux qu'il faudra qu'il y ait plus
de décès que les vies des phoques était
plus importante que celle des humains en
valorisant chaque partie de l'animal il
estime que les madelinots ont désormais
une nouvelle chasse à offrir on veut pas
faire disparaître le phoque gris nous on
veut juste contrôler espèces c'est notre
source à nous mais c'est ok mais c'est
une ressource qui va dès lors chaque
année qui pourrait être prélevée par du
monde ici pour un industrie aux îles
pendant notre séjour on a demandé aux
madelinots ce qui motivait autant
d'efforts pourquoi revenir à une chasse
qui a déjà terni l'image des il faut
être ici pour vraiment comprendre que ce
qui se passe on s'est rendu compte que
les populations de foi qui était très
important ça pouvait même être nuisible
de ce côté là
comme c'est juste à côté on a tout
avantage en tant qu'industrie de bien
s'occuper de cette chasse là
[Musique]
droite pop que ja c'est la chasser de
leur fai drh à sonoma on a toujours fait
ça et aussi que les bains sud
l'écosystème du golfe saint-laurent qui
est très fragile
faut accepter ce que là maintenant c'est
tout ce qu'on peut pas que les prix
soient bonnes ou moins bonnes mais on
est content pareil de pouvoir se nourrir
et nourrir pleinement parce que me veux
pas passer vendu un peu partout ailleurs
puis à tout le monde en profite
ce soit tout le temps un combo père
spirituel parce que c'est tellement
facile de nous faire mal paraître
chasseurs de phoques sur la banquise ou
sur la plage mais je pense que de la
fierté de saint victor
hop et il y autre chose que ça c'est
énorme